previously on TV since I've got my a
team on it we shall make the skies safe
the mumsy Daniel's Buckingham dog save
the queen
at least give it a break
reading also the fact that we are 10
years away from living in the 30s makes
me feel very very old and that it's
definitely us in kids I'm gonna tell you
an incredible story Bob Saget isn't
narrating the aristocrats joke in this
scene the story of How I Met Your Mother
ten seconds to roll commercials it's a
new record but also can you tell me the
story of what horrible thing you did to
the brandy decanters behind the couch
that looks like apple cider and brandy
really shouldn't look like apple cider
also the is up with this house the year
is 2030 man I expect everyone to be
dressed like an extra from demolition
man couch to be levitating in zero
gravity and those two Cantor's back
there to be filled with legal medicinal
grade weed instead of that discount
cider it was way back in 2005 the fact
that it's been 15 years since 2005 and
it actually is way back now makes me
feel very very old and that is
definitely a sin also have you noticed
how old people will forget they said
something and say it over and over again
we start them up there yup will you
marry me yes
perfect who that's to practice a simple
proposal you're not reciting the
presidents are juggling anything right
maybe I'm special but I managed to pull
it off on my first try with no practice
whatsoever it's physics Marshall if the
bottom bunk moves the top bunk moves too
and of course the laugh track is here to
reassure us that lines like this is
super hilarious what's worse is that
this show isn't even filmed in front of
a studio audience
so those manufactured giggles chortles
chuckles and guffaws are getting sent
extra just doing my job as a member of
your local law enforcement what was i
doing narration you were doing narration
there is no way this barber is shaving
any hair using the straight razor this
way lead with the blade against the
follicles this way you're basically just
petting the hair instead of kidding all
up in there and doing some work that's
up with the slap at the back of the head
seems like accommodating that no one
actually does no one with any friends
left at least Barney we met at the
urinal urinal introductions did this
show inspire Brooklyn nine-nine to spend
its entire pilot episode in a flashback
loop do I like this let's flash back to
all the times I've seen unimpressive
flashbacks and find out ya know this
isn't working for me we've got swipes
freeze frames whooshes and split screens
someone in the editing apartment was
born with the extra gene this bowl is
filled with waxy spheres and I must know
what these are bouncy balls throw fruit
we'll see it again in a few minutes and
some of these contents are gone or used
or consumed the only thing I can liken
them to or other colorful edible balls
from the original Willy Wonka I've
always wanted to eat one of those this
show reminded me that won't a fruit
isn't a real thing and really how dare
it was finger-painting day at school and
a five-year-old boy got to second base
with me I'm not a shocked than a
five-year-old copped a feel as I am that
he left such a perfect handprint no
splatter there are two big questions a
man has to ask in life I know this one
is it bigger than average and this
happens to all guys right yay for love
but dear God can you wait to bone until
after the milk is put away spoils I'm
sorry cause my boyfriend Carl is just
now giving Ted the stink eye Ted
straight-up took her from the bar to a
personal table and ordered her another
drink before this reveal the mixed
signals being sent are flavored for
humor but disappointingly watered down
how does Carl land a Lebanese girl more
importantly how does Carl not hear you
when you're standing right next to him
and talking in his direction take us to
the hospital
whoa whoa whoa did you hit her good to
know there's a moral compass in here
somewhere
so these spankings pajamas are au
naturale so what do you do I'm a
reporter for Metro news one and it's
absurd how successful this group of
friends are like even the adult
characters in it Chapter two think it's
crazy that everyone is eventually at or
near the top of their fields and don't
come at me with that Lily as a
schoolteacher bull crap because she's
doing the Lord's work and arguably is
the most successful I can't
I'm going to Orlando for a week on
Friday going to Orlando the next night I
took her out to this little bistro in
Brooklyn the show goes on for 207 more
episodes is this wretched man forcing
his children to listen to every goddamn
story of his serious about dating ears
because that is next level horrible dead
right there when you go on a first date
you really don't want to say Smurf penis
girls don't ordinarily like that but
this was no ordinary Girl
this girl loved Smurf penis in fact
children good old dad here went and
found periwinkle condoms and blueberry
flavor for later that night when I
revealed my Smurfs eyes to the woman of
my goddamn dreams Lily
how long have you been sitting there oh
come on Jason Segel is like 64 and
weighs at least 200 pounds I have
friends that size and I'd need to lose
at least four of my five senses to not
realize when they sat on a couch
directly next to me you quote obscure
lines from ghostbusters Ray when someone
asks you if you're a god you say yes is
that really an obscure line from
ghostbusters I would have accepted well
we only have 75 more to go or just like
the Philadelphia Mass turbulence of 1947
heck I might even have accepted
generally you don't see that kind of
behavior in a major appliance buck the
say yes line is one of the most quoted
lines of the movie also how does that
line come up in the midst of the
conversation without it being
specifically about ghostbusters look I
speak movie quotes it's my second
language and the trick is to work quotes
into natural conversation not just blurt
out movie quotes you like completely out
of context there you are we got a jumper
some crazy guy on the Manhattan Bridge
come on you're covering it
this is not how news reporting works
reporters are assigned on-call times for
stuff like this
and if you couldn't contact the person
you go on to the next person and load up
and go with them there is no world where
it makes sense to load up a van and go
driving around looking for a reporter
who you can't get in touch with also
this is 2005 certainly agent Hill would
have some sort of flip phone especially
if she's in the news game but plots got
a plot I guess I killed you Conner don't
make me get your mom Barney is 11
minutes old to me and he's already such
a douchebag that my first assumption is
that he was threatening to bone Connors
mom TV staging is the best isn't it in
what world do these for humans pick this
tiny table to sit at and even if they
did why would they sit like this unless
they know they are being filmed in a way
to get all four of them in one picture
she didn't even give me the signal
speaking of signals this man has been at
this table on his cell phone since
yesterday and damn they don't make cell
phone batteries like they used to also
go home buddy you're drunk
yes she is of course she is because in
this case News position not only gets to
further the story but also the
characters double news position for the
sin earlier you said you were I'm a
reporter for Metro news one but now you
call it Metro one news it's almost like
it's a fake place that you've never
actually worked at before excuse me
enjoy a coffee larceny a million
thoughts raced through my mind
unfortunately one particular thought did
not I've got five dogs five dogs and a
loft in Brooklyn Robyn must have paid
more for the pet deposit in this place
and the first six months of rent
combined I'm from Bangladesh the women
hot there here's a picture of my wife
know what is Feist are we supposed to
like Barney at all Duke deserves a handi
from Edward Scissorhands you have to
swear that this does not leave this cab
you're telling Barney what's up with TV
characters telling secrets to the most
morally questionable person in their
friend group hi have you met Barney okay
eyepatch gone no I was easy and her eye
makeup is already done I'm thinking
someone was faking that eye injury for
attention No okay fine haha they invited
the cab driver in for reasons but I'm
not buying that he's sitting here in
this shot when we already know what it
looks like when he's sitting here
relaxed in this shop it's almost like
that line and reveal was for an unseen
audience that the characters should know
nothing about because that kids is the
true story of how I met your aunt Robin
okay that's clever but the real twist is
that How I Met Your Mother would get us
in removal never saw that one coming did
you
when I was your age television was
called books that is in future future hi
I'm Ted
hi I'm gonna call 50 shades of fair on
you tonight I figure just isn't right to
drink champagne in Matador pants you
want to go out sometime
I'm sorry Carl's my boyfriend yeah we
get home safe pistol you got it Joe B
what you nicknamed me pistol and I just
called you Jobin instant boner that's
what I always say about you
my wife instant boner give her think I'm
in love with you what Steve he said a
bad language word